there's no denying that bighorn sheep
are cool they climb things bash their
heads into other sheep and they have
horns so why hasn't anyone ever created
a game where you can play as a bighorn
sheep well I'm happy to inform you that
a game like that exists right now the
game is called the slippery slope an
endless runner created by the FBI yes
the Federal Bureau of Investigation made
a game about bighorn sheep the game is
part of their don't be a puppet website
where it's designed to teach teenagers
how to avoid violent extremism so here's
the website's description as follows the
site doesn't refute violent extremist
beliefs point by point or discuss
matters of faith or politics instead it
makes teams aware of the destructive
reality of various forms of violent
extremism including hateful attacks
based on race religion and other factors
through its don't be a puppet theme the
program encourages teams to think for
themselves and display a healthy level
of skepticism if they come across anyone
who appears to be advocating extremist
violence so like diehard coldplay fans
who argue relentlessly that coldplay is
rock don't be a puppet folks you want to
try it out this game can be found in the
blame section of the website as you
complete levels you are given examples
of phrases that might lead to extremist
violence such as our group is under
attack or the enemy is responsible for
this injustice the game is only six
levels deep so it shouldn't take you
long to complete but the controls make
flappy birds seem like a finely tuned
gaming experience so if it's games
you're into then you are already in the
right place your fascination for sheet
brought you here you're strange but
thanks for the click